I just wanted to remind everybody about
something pretty special to us and
that's that our primetime special Conan
in Australia airs tomorrow April 17 at
10 o'clock p.m. this is another one of
our travel shows and this one it's a
it's a lot of fun I think we had a lot
of adventures here's just a tiny tiny
taste of what you're gonna see if you
tune in tomorrow this is a southern tray
funnel-web not just in trays they live
also under rocks this thing can kill me
absolutely yes within 20 minutes these
are under rocks so what's the way we've
just done the ropes so I'm just
gesturing around like they're everywhere
are they why are we here we just meet at
the Four Seasons Hotel lobby
you could have had iced teas and we
could have you should have show me the
same book the male echidna actually has
a four-pronged penis why why not she's
good
it's a lot of fun it's really fun
episode to see it all be sure to watch
our primetime special primetime Conan in
Australia airing tomorrow April 17th 10
o'clock p.m. also check out all the
Conan in Australia extras at team
koco.com slash oh yeah I'm really happy
about this one I gotta tell you we have
a lot of fun I saw some very cool
wildlife you're lucky Conan what do you
want someone gasped over here what do
you what do you mean I'm lucky you're
lucky the Warlord's didn't kill you okay
sir just calm down I saw plenty of
wildlife in Australia and I'm look at me
I'm fine yeah I guess getting coming
face-to-face with any of these deadly or
sea critters the saltwater crocodile
yeah I didn't I didn't see that now the
Eastern brown snake nope didn't see it
the Corman Death Adder definitely didn't
see any common death adders I'm
surprised they're pretty common how
about the Crocker donkey
these are stubborn as he is deadly Conan
you know I'm guessing that's not a real
animal it is so is the Hogan headed
lizard if it bites you you die from Hulk
Amin okay alright
now that is not a real thing now look
out for the bird flipping spider this
spider is always flipping you the bird
Conan it's infuriating
and beware of the bingo dingo for God's
and the Scorpio opium well wait a minute
what's a Scorpio or pian it's a scorpion
but it's also a store P oh and you know
how jealous Scorpios can get
look out evil parrot but for God's sake
how did you know that parrots evil I'll
come on look at him that parrot is up to
no good
just like homophobic Steve and I don't
think that's a real guy
really one Batman this billionaire
playboy warm bats parabola murdered and
ever since he's dedicated his life to
fighting crime
however since he's only got the brain of
a wombat he doesn't know what crime is
so we just fights everybody lightning
round
shocker ooh Wow Chi and lastly but not
leastly kangaroo you know I'm sorry I
get the impression you're a [ __ ] I
really do and if these animals didn't
get you you're lucky you didn't catch an
Australian disease like koala reah all
right Android okay dingo theory aha or
Mel Gibson's a Great Barrier T yeah a
bloomin onion Peter save for cancer of
the fever or opera cough cough cough
really annoying okay and one button all
right that's it
can't wait to see you Australia show
Conan alright thanks a lot you wasted
our time
welcome yeah good job you're welcome
good job good job